[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR HERMELIN: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for attending GCP
Next and coming to our session,
Learning Best Practices.
My name is Amir
Hermelin, and I'm
a Product Manager on
Google Cloud Platform,
and specifically I
focus on Stackdriver.
With me here is Thomas.
THOMAS RAST: Hi,
I'm Thomas Rast,
I'm an SRE on one
of the SRE teams
that runs the Stackdriver
back end part.
AMIR HERMELIN: And
we're here to talk today
about alerting best
practices and what we've
learned monitoring and alerting
services at scale at Google,
and also helping our users
monitor their services on cloud
platform.
A lot of the topics we cover
are included in this book,
"SRE, The Site Reliability
Engineering Handbook,"
and we'll also be giving
away a couple of these,
signed, at the end
of the session.
So worth sticking around.
THOMAS RAST: It's
signed by the VP of SRE,
which is kind of cool.
AMIR HERMELIN: So-- a little
bit, let's go over the agenda.
So we'll start with
a little history
on how monitoring and alerting
has evolved at Google.
Go over an overview and
some quick definitions,
just so, you know, we're
all on the same page.
And then we can dive into
the monitoring and alerting
philosophy.
The why, the what guides us
when we do the things we do.
Then we'll go into best
practices and lesson learn--
lessons learned, and this is
the more kind of practical part
of the session.
Towards the end, we'll talk
a little bit about suggested
processes, and then
we'll wrap up with Q&A.
So before we start, slides
are not self-explanatory,
so if you're just wrapping
up that tweet about how
wonderful this conference
is, go ahead and do that.
But then I suggest you
focus your attention on us,
and I really appreciate it.
THOMAS RAST: So
basically to frame
this talk, a very brief
history of monitoring
since about 2005 at Google.
We had a binary
there called Borgman.
It's actually--
it's in the book,
but you can think of it as
Prometheus in recent terms.
Prometheus is sort of an
external recreation of Borgmon.
It's a single binary
collection evaluation
type monitoring system.
And every team would run
their own, the core binary,
and it has service scale, but
you have to scale it manually.
You had to arrange it in tiers
and like, pass up aggregations
towards the global tier.
And there was already
sort of a movement
towards centralization,
so you'd have some support
infrastructure that
initially was per team,
but migrated to be run by
what then became production
monitoring SRE in about 2007
or so that I'm now a part of.
This infrastructure included
things like metamonitoring.
So you want to monitor that to
your Borgmons actually work,
otherwise monitoring
is kind of useless.
You'd have long term
history storage,
so you could serve queries
over multiple years,
and you would have the
alerting outbound part.
And in 2012, [INAUDIBLE]
took on Monarch
as the new state of the art.
Monarch is a large,
distributed monitoring system.
If you're interested,
there's a great talk by one
of the Monarch
TLs, John Banning,
given at Monitorama 2016,
you can find it online.
It is Google Scale
in one system,
so we actually literally monitor
all of Google in one monitoring
system, and it is monitoring
as a service in that as a user,
you only have to
provide a conflict.
This still requires
some knowledge, right.
I mean, hence, we're
here giving talks,
but it's much better than
having to run your own Borgmons.
And this gets us to Stackdriver.
AMIR HERMELIN: So in 2014,
we acquired Stackdriver,
and I want to emphasize
that Stackdriver
is a natural evolution
to our cloud users.
It does not replace what we've
been using for years at Google.
So instead of that, it
runs on top of Monarch
and on top of our alert
management system,
and it uses the
years of experience
of running services at scale.
But Stackdriver is geared solely
towards users of the cloud.
It was built for monitoring
cloud applications,
with a focus on easy getting
started experience, very
user friendly UI, and Mantra,
which is still true today,
which we strive to--
you don't have to be
an expert in monitoring
to monitor your services well.
So we prefer that you
focus your time and energy
more on innovation and
less on administration.
So that was true when
we acquired Stackdriver,
and it's true today.
Stackdriver has evolved to
be more than just monitoring.
So it offers a wide
range of other services,
and it supports not
just GCP but also AWS.
I'll cover that more
towards the end of our talk.
So now let's go over some
definitions, and so--
we're sure that we're all kind
of speaking the same language.
So these are commonly used terms
in monitoring and alerting.
Sometimes they're overloaded,
especially the alerting part.
So when we talk
about monitoring,
we're talking about you
know, measuring performance,
correctness, observing--
building instrumentation,
so that's really
extraction of metrics from our
application, from our services
into something useful that
we can use for dashboarding
and for alerting.
Logging is another type
of information extraction.
Logs are a little different than
regular metrics, in the sense
that they are immutable.
They have a timestamp, but they
can also serve for monitoring.
For example,
extracting metrics from
logs, putting them in
dashboards, alerting on them,
et cetera, et cetera.
Alerting, again, probably
the most overloaded term,
and it can be a verb and a noun.
So alerting is the process
of also configuring
your alert rules, and, you
know, maintaining them.
It's also the process of
detecting issues, opening
incidents, and informing is
sometimes also called alerting.
So the act of informing
users that something
is wrong with the services
that you're running.
Then we have debugging, or
figuring out the root cause.
That happens usually
after alerting.
It's getting down
to the problem,
it's mitigating the
problems, and at the end
when all is well
again, we sometimes
do postmortems,
kind of to make sure
that whatever happened
does not happen again
or is treated more efficiently.
THOMAS RAST: User impact
will be an important term,
and we gave it its own slide for
three definitions, the SL A, I,
and O. To measure
something like user impact,
SREs especially sets themselves
service level objectives.
So as an example, you might
have an uptime objective,
we're using uptime here
as sort of a health check.
You'd just issue an HTTP request
and see if it comes back,
of say, three 9s, right.
99.9% success.
And for every SLO,
you would track
the corresponding
indicator, that's
your SLI, which in
this case is uptime.
There's another term, SLA,
which is the actual business
agreement entered
into with customers.
The distinction
between A and O is
kind of irrelevant at this
talk, so we'll skip it.
One note here is
if you were aiming
to go for like, five
nines, because you heard,
I don't know, Google
does it or something,
be aware, with like
everything you hear later,
you only have five minutes
per year for your entire page
response up to mitigation if you
actually have anything happen.
AMIR HERMELIN: OK.
So before we dive into the
monitoring philosophy and best
practices, et cetera,
it's very important
to look at the process around
alerting and around monitoring
at a higher level.
So Thomas mentioned SLOs.
We start by actually
defining them.
You have to realize
what you want to monitor
before you start monitoring.
It sounds trivial, but we
find that sometimes people
do it the other way.
So think about what are your
SLOs, what you want to monitor,
what do you want to
put on dashboards,
what are you on instrument.
You make sure you
get those metrics,
either from the system
that you're using,
via system level metrics
or custom metrics,
and then when you
have all that, you
can start actually
configuring your alerts.
So you know what you're alerting
on, everything all is well,
and then an alert triggers.
So one thing we want to
emphasize with this diagram
is this process is iterative.
You're never really
at a point where
you have the perfect
configuration,
and there's nothing more to do.
Because things
change, realizations
change, SLOs change,
your service changes.
So it's an iterative process.
But especially in
the beginning, you
should be prepared
to kind of change
your alerting rules
and the way you alert.
So if an alert triggers,
usually an incident is open,
we use that term to
define like a problem
that somebody needs
to take care of.
So there a time span
an incident is active,
and notification is being sent.
So somebody is
handling the issue.
Now, the first thing to figure
out is if this issue is real.
If it is real, you need to
mitigate it, you know, debug,
maybe escalate.
But if it's not real, you need
to look at the alerting policy
that triggered rather than
just going-- getting back
to work and not waste time the
next time it triggers, and see
what you need to maybe
change in the alert policy
or maybe delete.
When all is said and done,
the incident is resolved.
If it was real and if
it was serious enough,
maybe a post-mortem is
needed, and we go back
to this cycle of iterating
on your alerting policies.
So now let's segue--
you know, we're done
with the definitions,
and we want to segue into a
little bit about monitoring,
what it is, and what
drives good monitoring.
So why do we monitor, right?
Why are you here, why do you
use a monitoring solution?
So these are kind of the--
probably the main use cases.
We monitor because we want
to detect and analyze trends.
It could be business metrics,
it could be service metrics.
We want to see for latency is
trending up or trending down,
or some resources are
trending to depletion.
I want to compare over time,
for example, its business
metrics we want know if
[INAUDIBLE] checkouts,
how do they compare it to the
last season or the last month?
If it's latency,
how does latency
compare to our error ratio
compared to last week?
We build dashboards, so we use
metrics to build dashboards.
So we have an at a
glance introspection
into our services, rather
than having to go and do
a lot of work each time we
want to get some answers
to basic questions.
Of course, we use
metrics for alerting,
which is the main topic
of this discussion,
and we also-- debugging
is not part of monitoring,
but it's very
strongly tied into it.
We use, sometimes,
instrument metrics
that will help us debug,
that will help us drill down.
We will go into that later.
Sometimes we instrument
dashboards just
for the debug part, just
for the firefighting part.
So it's important
to mention that.
So what you really want to
make sure you're monitoring.
This is what we call
the four golden signals.
And that's a painting
of the four horsemen,
so if you want to make
sure your service doesn't
get to Armageddon
level, you want
to make sure that you're
monitoring these things.
At least, right?
The first two are errors,
or error ratio, and latency.
Why this is important,
this is kind
of-- these are kind
of the outbound facing
metrics of your service.
This is how your users
view your service.
So if your latency is bad, or
if you have too many errors,
that's immediately reflected
in the quality of service
that you provide.
The other two, traffic,
which is self-explanatory,
and saturation, which is really
the level that your resources
are full or the level
that you're utilizing
your resources, you
can look at these
as king of the view of your
service towards the inside.
So this is what your
service, if it was a person,
this is what it would be seeing.
It's seeing the traffic,
and seeing the saturation
internally.
And these two can
lead to error--
you know, to errors
or bad experiences,
that will eventually
reflect on your users.
THOMAS RAST: So you're
measuring these four signals,
then there's a
question of how, right.
And we have an important
distinction here,
which is that the difference
between black box, or probing,
and white box monitoring.
So black box is if you
monitor from the outside,
treating the system as a
black box, hence the name.
The advantage here
is it's independent
in terms of failure
modes, at least
largely, usually, which
makes it more reliable
and is better for alerting.
One example here, I
mean, you might have
[INAUDIBLE] time check again.
For a stateful system you may
want a stateful probe, right?
You may want to, I don't
know, you have a file system,
you write a new file, put
some content in, read it
back, see if it comes
back, and then delete
it again to clean up.
And the opposite is monitoring
that works and the cooperation
of the system, which is great.
Because you get a
lot more detail.
And you'll need that detail
to do the actual debugging.
But again, the failure
modes may be tight,
and so you usually don't want
to rely on this for alerting.
A good example of one thing
you could not possibly
get from black box is
the bottom example.
If you compared
the actual memory
handed out by your
malloc, versus the memory
given to your process
by the operating system.
There's no way you can get
that without it being exported
from your process, right.
AMIR HERMELIN: So just
to put this in context
with the monitoring
solution that we offer,
just a show of hands,
how many of you
are familiar with Stackdriver?
Great, let's see--
83%.
That's good.
The ones that aren't,
you should be, but.
The way we offer
these, for example,
in Stackdriver, which most of
you should be familiar with
is--
black box monitoring
is our uptime check,
and you should be using that
to set up uptime checks.
To set up alerts
on these kind of--
and use probes from the outside.
White box monitoring,
so for example,
the system level metrics
that are provided
for your resources, for
example custom metrics that you
as users need to instrument.
For example, the logs that are
available via the Stackdriver
suites.
All of that is white
box monitoring.
THOMAS RAST: We have two
slides here about sort
of a pet peeve of mine.
An FAQ with monitoring
is, what is the difference
between those two graphs?
They're traffic,
monitored at the system.
In this case, the
difference is sampling rate.
So I made artificial
graphs to show the example,
but the left one has one
minute sampling rates
and the right one has
one second sampling rate.
Clicky.
If you have very short
spikes on the minute,
for example, which happens
surprisingly often,
you will never see them on
a typical one minute sampled
monitoring system.
And again, one minute
is really typical.
One second has a
significant overhead
in terms of how often you need
to go talk to your system,
how much it takes
to store that data.
And another one is, if
you look at distributions,
latencies in particular,
so the horizontal axis here
is latency.
If you're just
looking at the mean,
and maybe, I don't
know, mean plus sigmas,
you're already missing a lot.
Maybe you heard
about percentiles.
Percentiles are important,
but then the distribution
that motivated this slide
looks something like this.
This is from a caching
front-end for a storage system,
and so the behavior you see
is the very low latencies,
like sub-10 milliseconds
is a cache hit.
And the bump at something
like 600 milliseconds
is if it has to go
talk to its back end.
And this is exceedingly
common, and you
will fail to see it if you
only look at latencies--
percentiles, excuse me.
And this now gets
us to the philosophy
that you've been waiting for.
And we have three core points.
One, you should
really be alerting
on symptoms using SLOs.
We will have
something that you'll
see in a slide in a moment that
we call the JUAN criterion.
It's really good to remember it.
And we have a human
aspect that we'll discuss.
AMIR HERMELIN: So
the first thing--
this is a section, by the
way, about philosophy,
so we're going to
talk about the why,
and later we're going to show
some best practices more on the
how.
But the philosophy around
alerting on symptoms.
This focuses-- you
ask somebody that's
monitoring their services
on the things that
really matter to your users.
So by alerting only on
symptoms, or the vast majority
of your alerts related to
symptoms, that makes sure A,
that you're not wasting
time on meaningless alerts.
That may be alerting
on things that you
know you could avoid
notifying in the first place,
and also it focuses you on
really being-- the alerts being
tied to the quality of service
that your users are seeing.
The second part of our
philosophy is JUAN metrics.
These are metrics
that you should
put every alerting
policy through
to make sure that it's valid.
Assuming you have a
finite budget of time,
you don't want to be wasting
time on meaningless alerts.
So any alert that
doesn't pass this test
should be a candidate
for removal.
The first one is Judgment.
An alert should
require human judgment.
Otherwise, why waste
a person's time?
And also, it can really upset
people when they get frequently
alerted and they
feel like you know,
they don't have to
think or do anything,
it's just-- they don't
have to use any judgment.
And that causes churn.
It should be Urgent, either
right now or next business
day, because again, if
something isn't urgent,
why are you diverting focus
from other more important things
to this if it can wait for
a week or even a month?
It should be Actionable.
This one should be clear,
but I want to explain it.
It means that there
should be some action that
needs to be taken as a
result of this alert,
other than reading the
alert notification.
Now it doesn't mean--
it doesn't mean that you
can mitigate the problem.
Take, for example, I mean,
we know cloud providers,
they're always failure free.
But let's say your
cloud provider
has some sort of failure.
You should still know about
it, even though there's
not much you can do, except
email me and others and "Hey,
what's up?"
But even then you
want to maybe explain
to your users what's going
on, or through your page,
or through your
Twitter page, you know.
React to that, be on high
alert to maybe later divert
traffic et cetera, et cetera.
So that's an example where
something is actionable,
but it's not something that you
can do with fixing the service.
And last but not least,
definitely, is Necessary.
If it doesn't affect anything,
users, service, business,
why alert on that?
Maybe there are other,
more efficient ways.
THOMAS RAST: The human aspects.
The most important
one, we think,
is you have to consider
the stress budget.
Every alert triggers
a stress response.
This is good, right, you
need this adrenaline boost
to deal with the
alert, especially
if you're getting in the middle
of the night or something.
But this has a
cost to the human.
It's a very biological
thing, and you
need to make that budget last.
And there are two basic
ways you can do this.
You can keep the frequency
of alerting down,
just the pure number, or you can
make the human more confident
and thereby reduce the stress
for the individual alert.
And we call this providing help,
because if you support them
in especially the very
beginning of the response,
if they're better trained,
they have better documentation,
they will experience
less stress.
And the second
aspect of humans is
they're good at pattern
recognition and somewhat lazy.
Again, that's
[INAUDIBLE] automate
themselves out of their jobs.
In alerts especially, this
means that specifically
for actionable,
mostly, people will
realize that something
is not actionable
and start ignoring it,
at least subconsciously.
And so we have the
three core points.
Again, symptom based SLO alerts,
JUAN, and the human aspect,
and we'll now try and develop
some actual best practices
that follow from this.
First for SLOs, how do
you choose then an SLO?
All right, this is not
necessarily an alerting thing,
but it's very important because
it's the start of alerting.
You should really
bound it between what
your service can support
and what your customers can
support, all right.
So the service gives
you an upper bound
of how much you can ask, and
if you get that wrong, you've
put the SLO too tight, your
oncallers will burn out.
That's like the number one
risk, is you get too many pages,
your people burn out.
If you get the
lower bound wrong,
then your customers will leave.
So you have to get
it between those.
And just as a side note, the
three nines of uptime as an SRE
tenant, also means you
have 0.1% of downtime
you can use to break stuff,
take risks, do something.
So So we want to augment that--
are you all familiar
with the fail whale
and Twitter early days?
And we actually want to
bring up this example
as a positive example.
You can't always
be a perfectionist,
and you can't always meet
SLOs that please your users.
And sometimes you have to
make decisions and business
decisions, such as not meeting
your SLOs because you're
experiencing huge growth.
And the size of the
team, and the size
of the new users
you're getting everyday
is just too much
to meet your SLOs.
And that's fine, as long as
you make a conscious decision,
say you know what,
a lot of my users
are going to be seeing
this, or high latency,
or not being able to log
in, because right now it's
all hands on deck
focusing on growth.
But it has to be, of course,
in a controlled manner,
and you have to know why
you're not meeting your SLOs.
So let's look at
one's example metrics.
So we talk-- we
talked about why,
but let's take a few
examples for each--
for each of the
kind of four tests.
So first of all, judgment.
Good judgment is when
there's SLO alert,
right, you have to determine
where the problem is,
or there's some roll
out and you have
to determine if the
release is good.
Or maybe you have to
roll back the release.
So you have to make
some judgment there.
Bad example is when automated
actions, such as server
restarts, take care of
things and you still
get alerted on it.
Even though, you know,
the automated action
took care of things,
or when something can--
it isn't, but it can-- be
simply fixed with autoscaling.
If autoscaling is
doing its job, you
shouldn't be alerted on
it, even if resources
are kind of being stressed.
Another test is urgent.
So definitely SLO
and security issues
both are very, very urgent.
You should alert on all of them.
But if you find yourself
saying something like,
well, you know, if
this doesn't get fixed,
doesn't resolve itself in 12
hours, then we'll look at it.
That's a candidate to
kind of revisit the alert.
Maybe, again, you're
wasting time there.
And it's important-- the
reason we're emphasizing this
is, again, you have a limited
budget for your oncaller turn.
So you want to
spend that budget,
not get to alert
fatigue, you want
to spend it on the right things
versus the wrong things that
don't pass this test.
So another thing is actionable.
When you need to determine if
something needs rollback, when
you need to determine if
you need to add capacity
and it's not
automatically added.
A bad example, which is
actually quite common,
is alerting on CPU percentage
even though, again, autoscaling
can handle it.
So if autoscaling scales when
your CPUs are too stressed,
you don't need to alert on that.
Or another thing is
when issues go away.
So you see this, it alerted,
it was red, now it's green,
nobody looked at
it, and we go on.
And it costs time, even if
nobody handled that alert.
People look at it,
and it does cost time.
And of course, necessary.
So if it affects users, impacts
service, impacts business
metrics.
Anything else is not necessary.
If it's-- or if it's covered
by other alerting rules,
for example.
So you see these alerts that
fire with other alerts together
all the time.
So great candidates for removal.
Next, some best
practice examples
of how to think about symptoms.
So SLOs are a little
bit more obvious, right.
You have uptime, latency,
errors, error ratios,
but internal components,
you sometimes also
have to alert on them, right?
If you look at your
internal component
and think of it as
a service that's
servicing other
internal components,
then you can figure out what
are the SLOs of that component
towards its peers, and what are
kind of the black box metrics
that you want to
look at when you're
looking at that component.
For example, if you take
batch jobs, for example.
If they don't complete
on time, something
is happening in there, but that
might affect other services
and eventually that
will affect your users.
So you do want to alert on
that, and that's actually--
that is alerting on symptoms.
THOMAS RAST: We do concede that
if you-- if you have your SLO
alerts, sometimes there's
one more thing you really
want to do, and we
call these cliffs.
Because of how they measure
when the system fails
catastrophically, as in
drives itself off of a cliff.
And the typical case is
a resource alert, right.
If you write your
user data to disk,
and you run out of disks,
or disk quota, or whatever,
you're not going to space today.
And the advantage of then
having a 90% disk usage,
say, for example, alert, which
is a very typical thing to do,
is it gives you early warning.
The SLO alerts would only
fire once you've actually
exceeded your quota, and
things are actually broken.
I want to call out
a distinction here.
If SLO alerts are over paging
you and it's hurting you,
you need to go and
revise the SLO.
If a cliff alert is not giving
you good signal to noise,
just delete it, right.
There's nothing else to
adjust, just delete the alert.
AMIR HERMELIN: So now we want
to spend the next few slides
talking about the
human factor, which
is very important in the
alerting equation, and really
around two main things.
One is what's called alerting
fatigue, or alerting frequency,
and kind of alerting overload.
And it's a big problem,
especially on services scale.
And the other is
remembering that
at the other end of
the alerting policy
that you configure today,
another person, completely
different person,
might be paged.
So how do we deal with that?
So firstly, with
frequency limits, Thomas,
what have we learned
over the years?
AMIR HERMELIN: So SRE has
a fairly firm guideline
of having two outages per 12
hour shift on average, at most.
You will note I said outages.
If you have multiple pages
fighting for the same outage,
it shouldn't be many,
right, but it's frequently
hard to get it down to really
one on like, for every outage.
So we don't insist on that.
It should be a few, but the
two outages for 12 hour shifts
are important.
If you get significantly more
than this, you'll have burnout.
This can be at an actual
individual level, where someone
literally gets burn out.
It can be at the team
level, where morale sinks,
people leave, and you will get--
sort of, I would call it
quality decrease, right?
People don't consciously
ignore alerts,
but subconsciously they kind of
no longer have the bandwidth,
they do shallow investigations,
the postmortems don't really
root cause anything, you're
never really fixing anything.
And so you're never digging
yourself out of that hole.
You might have far
fewer, though I
have to say in a sort of second
law of thermodynamics sense,
this never happens, because the
number of pages only increases,
unless you have an active
investment to decrease it.
But if this were to
happen, all right,
you might have this,
consider two points.
One is handling pages
gives you a lot of practice
with the system.
It's sort of the most
hands on thing you can do.
You can compensate this,
you can do training, right,
that's not a problem, but
you need to make an effort.
And you may also ask
yourself is the investment
in having SRE support
warranted if they're not even
getting any pages.
And I have some examples here.
I want to go in some
detail into the first one,
the alert cried wolf problem.
We had a subsystem
of Monarch that
would, on average, like once
or a couple of times per week,
have a problem.
And the problem would go
away, sometimes he would tweak
a setting, sometimes
you wouldn't.
Eventually it would
go away, and that
that led to sort of this
conditioning that I mentioned.
It's the subconscious you know
this isn't really a thing,
and eventually, of course,
the inevitable happens
and we had a real problem.
And it was unnoticed for a week.
Even though if you
knew where to look,
you could tell that it was
a completely catastrophic
failure.
That system was not
making any progress.
It was a [INAUDIBLE] pipeline.
And of course,
like in proportion
to it being stuck in
that state for a week,
also that the magnitude
of the problem
then increased, and you
really want to avoid this.
Like, you see this
pattern when people
say the alert went
away by itself,
and then push back on it.
The other two, I think, are
somewhat self-explanatory.
I just wanted to
mention I observed
all of these firsthand, all
right, and so all of this
does happen.
Watch out for it.
AMIR HERMELIN: So this is how
fatigue actually looks like.
This is a screenshot
from Stackdriver.
The red lines and dots at the
top are alerting incidents,
and this is a time span
from 5:00 AM to 8:00 AM.
Now, you know, how
many of you want
to be looking at
this at 8:00 AM?
Raise your hands.
Yeah, and you have
to go and figure out
which of these alerts are real,
and how many issues you have,
and what to do with them.
You know, that's
clearly too many.
At 8:00 AM, you know, you
want to be drinking coffee
and reading the politics
section of the newspaper,
but not looking at this.
So that's an example.
THOMAS RAST: When we're done,
on the first thing you do after
getting a page, you will--
especially if it's an SLO based
page, right--
it's probably coming from a
prober, after what we told you.
In a simple case, the prober
might have some backends.
For simplicity, I put two.
You'll want to know is the
problem with one of those,
or is it somewhere
behind them, so
that they uniformly get errors.
And we call this drill down.
And the drill down might look
something like these two graphs
that we have on the next slide.
And it tells you, right.
In the first case, you probably
assume it's some back end,
and the second case, clearly one
of the servers is responsible.
You just need to hover over
the line and restart that guy.
I mention this, because
frequently in a real example,
you will have a load
balancer in between,
and you need to think
about how you're
going to do the signal
which back ends you picked.
Like, how you're extracting
that from the prober
before the pages happen, right?
Because otherwise you're blind,
and you cannot drill down when
you actually have
an SLO violation.
AMIR HERMELIN: So
the other thing
you want to do to help the
human is use dashboards
and use what we
call documentation.
In Stackdriver, sometimes it's
called referred to as Runbooks.
You want to make sure that
whoever responds understands
what the alert is about, what
was violated, what's the SLO.
Understand the subsystem,
what subsystem it relates to,
you know, in your service.
Where to go, how to mitigate.
You have to provide that,
especially up front,
and the path to escalation.
Now, the most common
mistakes that are made
are around mitigation
and escalation,
because when somebody
responds, especially
if you're going meet
a high level of nines,
the tendency is to
go and debug and fix.
But actually, the first
thing you want to make sure
is that the problem
is mitigated.
Maybe it's already
mitigated, but it's
going to crash
very soon, or maybe
you have to do something about
it, like roll back, et cetera.
That's the first
thing you should do.
And then escalation,
whoever's in charge of this
should provide clear
escalation path,
and also, it's desirable to add
escalation timeline so people
don't spend too much time
being stuck before they
refer to their colleagues.
So that was kind of--
those last few slides were
about helping the human.
Now we go into another thing,
which is notification methods.
You want to have redundancy
with your notification methods,
and not rely on a single
alerting notification methods.
Because problems can occur at
the sending end, or problems
can occur at the receiving
end, where the oncall is not
able to receive that
type of notification.
So if it's just n+1, on
the right side you have
a Stackdriver screenshot.
It's very easy to add additional
notification channels.
The free tier includes email
and cloud console apps,
so we recommend you
use both of them
for all your alerting policies.
If you have it, if you want
additional methods you can use
oncall software like--
and rotation software
like Pager Duty.
You can use chat applications,
Webhook, or SMS to add to that.
THOMAS RAST: I went to call
out SMS here as necessary.
Not because it's
especially reliable,
it totally isn't, but
it's the most independent
from all the others among these.
So if you pick three methods,
I suggest you put SMS there,
because it gives
you an independence
from all of the others
dying simultaneously
to some issue in the system.
And we have an example of
this actually happening.
I mean, it's really embarrassing
if your pager, fails especially
if you're on [INAUDIBLE]
and you're supposed
to keep the pager running.
We had an example, where
due to a mail loop, where
every outgoing page would
loop back through mail
and become a new page, we
delivered about 100 pages
per second to a single person.
Click and show the image.
AMIR HERMELIN: Oh there he is.
[LAUGHTER]
THOMAS RAST: So I have to admit
this is for a different outage,
but that one was
on a similar scale.
The poor guy actually received
A large number of pages.
What happened was, we--
for the internal one, for
the internal paging app,
we use an app engine,
Server Backend,
and we just used up the
entire quota of that backend.
And so it became
nonfunctional for all of SRE
until someone managed to
intervene about 2 and 1/2 hours
in or so.
AMIR HERMELIN: I must say
he looks happy for someone
that received so many--
THOMAS RAST: He got a t-shirt.
Engineers are always happy
when they get a t-shirt.
AMIR HERMELIN: That's
totally worth it.
Something that you might
be more familiar with,
because it was
very, very public,
is the DNS outage of late 2016.
Many, many prominent services
went down, and you know,
even though our services
were still up and running,
a lot of third parties
were experiencing failure.
So we got a lot
of support calls,
because users were relying
on one service that
might have gone down, or
the APIs are not available,
or the email gets rate
limited, so again, very
important to have
redundancy with the way
your alerts are
getting delivered.
So here are some additional best
practices, kind of each one,
each slide stands on its own.
One thing is grouping.
So you want to
reduce your alerts,
especially similar
alerts that kind of--
policies that do the
same thing for a bunch
of resources that act in unison.
You want to group them
together into a single policy.
If its Stackdriver, you
can use Stackdriver groups,
which is kind of a concept that
is inherent in the platform.
But think about
when problems occur,
you don't want to
get paged 100 times.
You want one alerting
policy to fire,
and then you know
that it relates
to a group of resources.
One thing to note,
though, and remember
is that if you're
doing this, you
have to have efficient
drill down mechanisms,
because in many cases,
when that alert fires,
you will have to kind
of investigate and see
which of the resources, which
components of the group,
are misbehaving.
And you know, that 100 page
storm that we saw earlier
might sound funny,
and that person
was smiling after
he got the t-shirt,
but it does happen every year
or two, even inside of Google.
So be prepared for that,
and be ahead of the curve.
THOMAS RAST: You know how
to [INAUDIBLE] 100 pages
that arrive simultaneously?
AMIR HERMELIN: You do a lot of--
THOMAS RAST: So we have two more
slides on process, just like,
some brief notes.
If you organize a
non-code rotation,
our guideline in SRE is for--
I mean, that's for a
quick response, right.
24/7 coverage, five
minute response time
to working on the problem,
being at the laptop.
You want 2 times 6 people
in different time zones,
or eight people in
the same time zone.
Again, this is just
a burnout problem.
They'll be on call too much,
if you have fewer people,
and then they'll
burn out over time.
Similar to how you have
n+1 notification methods,
you should probably have
n+1 people who get notified.
I don't know, the primary might
be on the New York subway,
they don't have any
reception there.
So we recommend you
have a secondary.
This could be someone
from some other rotation
or someone on the team, and
then if that still doesn't work,
you escalate to the entire
team, because you just
need a panic mode, I guess.
And what's really worked
for us is having--
I mean, if you're doing
weekly shift anyways,
it makes a lot of
sense, having a weekly
on call handoff meeting.
This should only take, I
don't now, half an hour.
And postmortem process.
I mean, you probably know
the basic drill, right?
One thing to call out here is
we generally write postmortems
when either the outage
was announced widely,
even internally, or
there was user impact.
But this is somewhat circular,
because in the other direction,
the saying goes, you should
really announce widely,
internally, at least,
if you think you're
going to write a postmortem.
People learn and develop
some experience for this.
And one thing to remember
in the context of alerting,
is it's somewhat
tempting in a postmortem
to draw as an action
item, add an alert.
This should not usually be
your only action item, right.
It's justified to
add an alert, if you
could have detected the problem
sooner by having this alert,
but you should still go
and fix the root cause.
And postmortems that say add
an alert and nothing else
are how you get into a situation
where you have page overload.
AMIR HERMELIN: So with
all these best practices,
we didn't say anything
about Google platform yet,
and we didn't include any plug.
So the best best practice,
in my mind, is that running--
remember, running monitoring
yourself is a lot of overhead,
and folks like Thomas
are hard to come by
and they're not free.
So the best thing
to do is actually
let somebody else
do your monitoring.
Additionally, if you're
running your own monitoring,
you have to make sure that
it's running correctly,
which is called metamonitoring,
monitoring your monitoring.
Instead, Google Cloud Platform
does offer a Stackdriver,
and as I mentioned it's
more than just monitoring.
It's an integrated
suite of products
that includes
monitoring, logging,
alerting functionality, trace
debug and error reporting,
and it's very, very
tightly integrated.
So for example, a log that you
ingest goes into the logging
and you can analyze it there,
but if that's an error,
it can also trigger
error reporting.
It could also trigger an alert.
You can take that log and
extract metrics from it,
put it in dashboards, alert on
these, or do whatever you want.
So the nice thing about
it is it's all integrated,
out of the box,
great experience.
And there's a free trial,
there's also a free tier,
you know, if you're not
using it to a large extent,
you could stay on the free tier.
But even premium's pricing
is very, very competitive.
To our discussion
today, it's also
geared towards helping you
utilize your time better,
and actually implement best
practices around alerting.
So it does offer
uptime checks to help
you focus around SLOs, to help
you focus around symptoms.
It offers multiple notification
methods, and Runbooks,
and other kind of
custom dashboards
to help the person that's
responding respond efficiently
to alert notifications.
It offers great
drill down component,
so really, we take
our experience here
and we use it when we're
implementing these services.
So let's see if we
remember everything.
If you have to remember
just one slide,
remember the one with
the guy in the t-shirt.
No, just kidding,
remember this slide.
Let's quickly go over it.
The four golden signals, you
should be monitoring them.
Latency and traffic,
how your service is
viewed from the outside, and--
sorry latency and
errors, how your service
is viewed from the outside,
traffic and saturation, how
your service looks from
the outside inside.
JUAN, every alert
policy should be
tested to meet these criteria.
Judgment, every alert
should be Urgent,
should be Actionable,
and definitely Necessary.
You should be alerting mostly if
not entirely only on symptoms,
and these include
SLOs, and you can also
alert on cliffs that
will induce symptoms.
Don't forget the human factor,
so limit alert fatigue.
Limit the amount of pages that
somebody can get in a shift.
Built in debugability,
building the ability
to mitigate, and help
the oncaller mitigate,
and provide a clear escalation
path for when people get stuck.
More than one notification
method is the next thing.
Use email, use the cloud
console app, SMS, whatever,
but use more than one.
And lastly, remember that the
process is iterative, right.
So you have to
respond efficiently,
you have to configure
your alerts efficiently,
you have to mitigate,
and also postmortem.
Even when the problem
is gone, let's
make things efficient
the next time around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]